we just got in a bunch of brand new Macs
so let their real world Mac videos begin
and today we are going to start out by
taking apart the new 15-inch MacBook Air
and seeing what Apple hid inside and
what they have changed guys you don't
know how excited I am I've waited for
years for a 15 inch MacBook Air and I
think it is gonna be the best selling
Mac laptop for the rest of this year now
we're gonna do a ton of real world tests
so make sure you guys hit that subscribe
button if you guys want to see how these
Macs compare and how to make the best
choice for you now First Impressions I
have not touched this yet this seems
very similar to the M2 version
um actually I thought it'd feel larger
in the hand it barely seems larger than
the 13. let's open it up all right now
that screen that sound
dang you definitely notice the screen
difference though now while this loads
up oh
but this thing is so light weight 3.3
pounds and it feels so rigid now I read
an article about how Apple chose to go
with the size and why it's slightly
thicker they wanted to make sure it's
rigid no flex super high quality and it
is here now it hurts me to not be able
to test out the new speakers or thermal
throttling just yet because we're gonna
take it apart first but make sure you
have notifications enabled for that
video because it's coming out tomorrow
let's Jump Right In and start unscrewing
this cover and it's really interesting
how we literally just have four screws
whereas like the previous 15-inch
MacBook Pro had a ton of them before we
lift that cover let's get our comparison
13 inch opened up here here is that 13
inch as you guys see we have a few marks
on it because we did do the teardown for
this one you guys see it is beautiful
and clean here we're gonna have to take
a lot apart you don't just see all the
parts Here and Now moment of truth let's
pop up this new 15 inch oh those clips
are strong maybe because this thing's
brand new and that is holding so well oh
that unlocked there all right guys
Moment of Truth
bam look at that wow okay but even I
just took a look and we counted seven
very obvious differences plus a few
minor ones even just at the bottom of
these now the first and most obvious one
are the speakers here on the 13 inch you
guys see we have these kind of magnets
on the back and it's just this upper
part but look at the 15 inch we have
these brand new modules that are massive
they take up so much room here and I
can't wait to hear the difference the
next one is these brand new clips right
here no wonder it's so hard to take the
cover off on a 13 inch you just have
these little pieces of metal with these
little cutouts don't move here these
actually move around which makes it
easier to find the right spot but then
it actually has tension to hold in
better and then we have the batteries
obviously the battery is larger but if
you guys look this actually has a split
battery redesign compared to a solid one
it's interesting that they chose to do
that in with that on the 13 inch the
battery actually goes all the way to the
edge here where the 15 inch it does not
and instead of having a bigger Gap they
actually added these pieces of metal
probably to make sure there's not too
much space and so the whole MacBook is
more rigid now with that the whole
design is more sturdy if you guys take a
look there's all these sections that
have more metal added to add to the high
quality rigid design instead of just
having more cut out the next one is the
hinge design you guys could see we
actually have two screws here plus the
bottom cover that goes through instead
of just having one on the 13 inch and I
read an article about an apple exec
talking about how much time they spend
on this thing to make sure the quality
and the build is incredible they did not
have to do this they could have made it
lighter weight but they didn't and with
that we also have a change to the ribbon
cable it's very thin but it is a lot
smaller overall compared to the 13 inch
now what is Wild is that the actual
motherboard is actually shorter on the
15 inch than on the 13 we have 11 and a
quarter inches there and here we have an
11 inch total overall Apple could have
easily just reused the same one but they
wanted to make the speakers bigger and
better so they changed the design which
costs money instead of reusing it now
there are a few other minor differences
in materials and covers but the next
thing is to start unscrewing this
motherboard now I already removed a
bunch of screws to save you guys time
but it's interesting that Apple has made
some changes to make this easier to
service but one of them that they didn't
do is the speakers because you now have
to remove them in order to get this
motherboard out you you even have to get
the hinges off in order to get the
speakers out in order to get this top
cover off all right the speaker is
coming out here
we do have a cable
underneath here here we go
and look at that we have the woofer
right there
that looks to be a tweeter and where is
the third speaker this just looks like
enclosures
do you think it's sit my team
look at that tiny little thing that must
be a tweeter
wow okay I don't want to damage it but
it does slightly move this is crazy look
at that difference in different
thickness and I don't know if that's a
little port or something but we have
those cutouts this is how you know that
Apple cares about speaker quality and
this thing is the antenna look at that
these enclosures here with the two
cables for all the connections you're
gonna have a good signal and now we can
remove some cables here and pull this
out now this here is a little top metal
cover to protect the motherboard uh
maybe for any kind of radio frequency or
interference so it doesn't do much all
right guys we've been working at it and
apple definitely made this harder than
the 13 inch and the crazy thing is if
your 15 inch brakes they won't want to
repair it they'll literally rather give
you a new one instead of taking it apart
and I see why you literally cannot
unplug any of these ports right here
without peeling back the whole heatsink
and then here we actually have a little
daughter board for some of the chips and
some of the connections which we didn't
have before hey guys this is scary stuff
it is a major amount of work to try to
take this cover off very carefully
finally we can access those cables and
look at this guys to me this seems a lot
thicker than the previous one this tape
looks different we have these bumps here
they definitely change this up and here
we go guys finally the M2 motherboard is
Unleashed I don't think Apple's ever
going to be doing this what we just did
but look at that now you guys might
notice right up top here oh no we have a
single nand chip with a completely empty
spot for the second one meaning the base
model is going to have half the speed
it's going to be actually slower than a
base model iPad Air both for read and
write which is insane that's a 64 gig
and the reason they're doing this is
because a single 256 gig named chip is
actually cheaper than a single 128
gigabyte which is absolutely crazy so if
they did the old method they would pay
more than double and they don't want to
do that in the M2 Chip actually allows
them to use a single one whereas the M1
require two so those are still fast and
that right there ladies and gentlemen is
the M2 Chip with the ram right on the
side this one has eight gigs it's a base
model and it's crazy how the Ram is
literally part of the CPU showing why
unified memory works really really well
and there is your whole computer now I'm
going to replace that thermal paste with
something that's pretty much what Apple
uses we tested the 13 inch before The
Thermals everything was identical to a
brand new model and then we'll get to
testing of course we have some other
Macs as well so go ahead and click that
Circle above to subscribe and check out
one of those great videos right over
there and we will see you in the next
one
[Music]
foreign